our kids anything they're literally
constantly and probably dressing up and
our kids are obsessed with Wizard of Oz
and Dorothy so they've been Dorothy
every year so we're like well this early
naturally awesome financially great but
we're like let's you know maybe we could
do like a bloody Dorothy like I can just
put some blood on you or something cuz
really Dorothy again you want to like
you know it's kind of awesome because
what my daughter did was tell me she
wanted to be princess and black were
reading these books then there is no
costume for that I had to make it happen
and put all together with all my free
time she was like never mind I want to
be Anna and I'm like and then I get on
and she's like I don't know wondering
I'm like you're gonna wear it which my
daughter changes her mind all the time
our five-year-old yeah I would love it
if she wanted to be Dorothy every
Halloween every Halloween is magical so
what's she going with you don't know I
have no idea she can wear a sheet for
all I care and be a ghost at this point
I am Pat are you the kind of mom like do
you make the thing you know no I'll get
on Etsy with all those mamas they have
time to bake I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this